what is up everybody welcome to the
gratitude Journal live stream edition
number 9 happy Thursday morning super
excited to be here with you guys again
today for another live stream so the
idea here is that we show daily
gratitude and it's part of a daily
ritual that you do to remind yourself of
the things that you have that are
positive in your life and that's that's
what helps get you through to it helps
you have good appreciation brings more
happiness helps get you through the hard
times a sad times the rough times you
might be facing because entrepreneurship
is a hard road in just just staying
positive and same gratitude a grateful
can be a big part of you continuing on
with your success and keep that momentum
going
and so the to keep one that its daily
it's every day it's not just oh I feel
grateful today and then for the rest of
the week you're not doing anything I do
this with my team every single day and
so now I'm bringing it to you guys
believe nation and the second part is
that you really feel it you feel it in
your core you feel it in your soul it's
not just listing stuff off because you
don't get the benefits unless you have
an emotional reaction you've got to
really really really feel it not just
think about it but feel it here in your
heart that's the difference so I'm going
to share three things that I'm grateful
for today and I'm hoping you guys
watching live will share it in the chat
we always have a awesome live chat for
the people joining in and for those of
you watching after the fact leave in the
comments below three things that you are
really truly grateful for and spend you
know spend a minute on each just feeling
it so that you can set your day off on
the right foot so for me let me see
through things for me today I'm really
grateful that my allergies are under
control I am really grateful my
allergies in the control uh for some
reason maybe five years ago I started
getting really bad allergies I'm
allergic to trees to grass that's pretty
much it trees and grass but grass is you
know almost all year long right apart
from our winter and I take an allergy
shot every year but it only lasts
certain number of times and so once that
other shot wears off I'm back to
suffering mode and I was taking a daily
pill and it wasn't working like it had
some effects but it was still every day
sniffling sniffling sneezing sniffling
you may have noticed it on the live
streams and J reyez friend of the
channel in the chat going to be joining
me on the League of Legends business Q&A
afterwards he gave me a health care pack
that had all this alert anti allergy
stuff and I've got to hear so the main
thing I've been doing daily is there's
this nettle tea that I've been drinking
with organic honey and that's part of my
daily regimen now that I
and that's been very helpful for me so
I'm still taking allergy pill we'll see
I might I might wean off and see how
that goes but super grateful for 4j your
eyes helping me out there and having my
allergies that under control second
thing I'm grateful for is I did a live
stream last night with Tim Schmoyer he's
got this youtube entrepreneur mastermind
group thing that he publishes every
wednesday at ten o'clock eastern which i
highly recommend checking out i was part
of his first series and I noticed that
somebody was somebody dropped and they
weren't on the call and said hey listen
if you need some of the sub in let me
know and you know you've done so much
work for the entrepreneur I'd love to be
able to help out if I can and so I
subbed in last night he's looking for a
replacement but I subbed in for the
night and it was an awesome session
helps some entrepreneurs the down part
was I couldn't sleep after so its up
till two in the morning just coming down
from the high of you know the energy
from talking entrepreneurs so that was a
downside but I was grateful for the
opportunity good for everything that Tim
does and and also just a message for you
guys you know that was just a simple
email to Tim there's probably people in
your life who might need a hand with
something might need help with something
you see that their their their dad a
person or you aren't able to lend a hand
uh just in a quick email to let you know
that you're there for them but you might
be able to help somebody out today and
the third thing I'm gonna go with that
the friendship of alex alex is the guy
who works with me at trauma dance salsa
you've seen him on some of the videos he
joined in on the league of legends live
stream earlier this week to sing happy
birthday to Jay rise alex is sick right
now he's sick right now so let's give it
up for Alex in the comments show him
some love his wife is sick right now too
so they're they're not here he's not
here as you normally is she's at home
sick but I'm just grateful
for having met Alex watching him grow
over the past year our friendship his
honesty his his willingness to learn his
increasing desire to take on
uncomfortable tasks he's really stepped
up and I'm it's been amazing watching
his growth and journey so I'm really
grateful for that so that's it those are
my three we've got five minutes left I
want you guys to list it up in the chat
let's give some shoutouts and see what
you're grateful for let's get a cup of
gratitude going on as we she might say
let's see we got J reyez thankful for
abundant plumbing abundant plumbing and
electricity for moving compelling
stories for the world's bold
trailblazing pioneers for valuable
entrepreneurs who serve humanity I love
it I love it what else do we have what
else do we have Greipel for compelling
names that resonate and rally people
what else welcome Rishi welcome antoine
welcome red uh chandi grateful for music
what would life be without music I live
for music I agree I mean the one of the
first things I do when I wake up is I go
and I put on my belief playlist which is
mostly mostly music mostly songs and
it's just the fastest way to change your
state you know if you're tired or your
dad or you're sad and you put on a song
that you love it just changes your mood
and so that list for me and I encourage
everybody to do this the playlist is is
public you can check it out but it's
really specific to my taste what you
want is music that makes you dance music
that when it comes on you just want to
do something right get you moving
because movement leads to a happiness
emotion to write it gets you off your
feet and gets you in the right state of
mind to go have a killer day as an
entrepreneur so thank you for that
gratitude Chandi what's up hater hater
not hater h AI de our hope i pronounced
okay hater Rishi cap TV is grateful for
music it's the second music wow look at
that I love it music creativity arts and
dance Antoine fellow Canadian grateful
for my mother whose birthday is today
what's up Antoine's mother you did an
amazing job raising an honest dedicated
passionate entrepreneurial song that
wants to go have an impact so give it up
for Antoine's mom in the comments we
appreciate you what else what else
allergy immunity yes Justin hello
wonderful people what's up Justin also
grateful for yoga the people who
practice it initially knew exactly what
was needed to set things straight I went
to them big time hashtag yogi I love I
haven't really gotten into yoga with
we've looked at it at Toronto dance
salsa maybe I gotta get back into it see
we gotta find the right spot the right
instructor you need the right instructor
they know grateful for not having any
allergies listen man if you've had any
kind of allergies you know how good it
is to not have them when they're not
around new future bill they're welcome
Justin I'm grateful to be able to go on
a run nice and early in a safe place
with excellent weather I love that get
in the morning start with some early
cardio a rest day 2103 ungrateful I'm
going for arrested 2103 giving some
awesome feedback on the one word landing
page for the book thank you for that man
I'm for always having followed my
intuition for the past two years which
has led me to unbelievable things in my
life I love it and very true sad I just
had an eye on this girl in the cafe and
my acquaintance just scored how do I
work around that join our live stream
afterwards on legal edges on my twitch
channel and we could talk about stuff
Antoine grateful for my mentor who's
helped me for one year now with
invaluable advice I love it youthful
moisture you
utiful moisture utiful moisture grateful
to be alive we prefer a relationship
with God creepy for family and friends I
love it flatty mug I'm before I'm before
I'm alive today to we got back to about
gratitude for being alive listen that's
it guys 9-10 a.m. here I go off have an
amazing day feel it every morning three
things that you are grateful for in your
life it will make a positive impact I
guarantee it on your happiness level and
the people around you too I'm going to
hop on a twitch channel answer some
business questions with rishi cup TV and
j reyez have an amazing day I've got six
other live streams seven of the live
stream something like that happening
today it's pretty crazy so see you there
continue to believe whatever your one
word is CC you guys